this this q and stuff that will never
we'll never get rid of conspiracy
theories we'll never fully get rid of
fascism i mean these are ideas
and that's that's what you get when you
have freedom
is you're gonna have some people that
have really [ __ ] bad ideas
because it's their freedom to have bad
ideas it's their freedom
by bad ideas but that's where our unity
needs to come from
we need to unify uh together
to be against these horrible
horrible [ __ ] ideas and crush them
and the biggest one is fascism
and that's where a lot of this neo-nazi
white supremacy stuff is born and that's
where it bled into q anon
which q anon bled into american
christianity really well too
um and and that's that's really [ __ ]
unfortunate but
that's what has happened in this country
and i think that's that's going to be
the long road that we have i think joe
biden
uh will be a a decent president now
history is going
to be very kind to joe biden and the
reason why i think history is going to
be kind to joe biden is because he's
he he's he's right after trump
so he's always always always always
going to be compared to trump which is
always going to put him in the category
of a damn good president i mean anybody
anybody compared to this [ __ ]
especially
this legacy of january 6 because that's
going to be his legacy folks is he tried
to overthrow the constitution
he tried to commit a coup and he's gonna
probably be found guilty in the senate
of it
if not in a federal court in a federal
criminal donald trump promise
to build a wall and mexico would pay for
it
so he he kind of builds a wall part of
it fell
over with a stiff wind and mexico did
not pay for it
which is why steve bannon created a
group
to raise money from trump supporters
people who voted for trump
to raise money to build their own wall
then steve bannon stole the money
he took the money from the trump
supporters so trump promised to build a
wall he promised mexico would pay for it
mexico did not pay for it
he had steve bannon go raise money but
steve bannon steals the money from them
and then trump pardons him from stealing
the money fleecing the money from his
supporters
what and how you couldn't even [ __ ]
make this [ __ ] up this face-off theory
what the actual [ __ ]
you guys have seen the movie with john
travolta and nicholas cage in it
um i don't remember what year is from
but it's surely from the 90s
but where they switch faces and in the
movie it's really
[ __ ] cheesy because they switch faces
but they don't switch bodies
and it and they obviously are not built
the same
why they picked two actors that had two
different body types i don't know but
they did
and it's the movie's totally
unbelievable
on its face no pun intended
but these people are spreading around
that
that donald trump is wearing joe biden's
face
somehow or joe biden's a hologram i've
heard this one too joe biden's a
hologram
this is the nonsense this is the
nonsense
this is like tr and it's like trying to
argue with people
who believe the movie star wars is real
i think if the republicans had any honor
here which they've shown that they still
don't over this last week
because of these this [ __ ] about
unity that they've been talking about
you know don't blame us we want unity
don't blame us please please don't hold
us to account because we want unity
you said you want unity don't hold us to
account well someone needs to be held
[ __ ] accountable for what happened on
january 6th
and if there are members of the congress
and members of the senate who had
anything to do with it and i'm talking
to you takers and josh hawley too
and by god they need to be held
accountable
so we'll see what happens with that and
we need to keep calling for these people
to be expelled
for what pardon is the pardon that i
wanted the most of all
i wanted him to pardon joe exotic and
it's not because i think joe exotic
is not guilty or that he should be
pardoned
i just selfishly want a season
two of tiger king i mean
is is that is that's [ __ ] selfish of
me that i want a season two of tiger
king that
i think trump should apply if there was
one that i could pick
like please like if i could lobby trump
say all right man
i know you got a list of 500 names that
you
that you're gonna wanna pardon but why
not
why not give your fellow reality tv show
[ __ ] bag a [ __ ] pardon i mean think
about it you could even maybe produce
the show
right come on you're a great reality tv
show we've had reality tv president for
the last four years
this would be perfect as a fan of the
kansas city chiefs realizes
that kansas city chiefs
are not in kansas they're in
[ __ ] missouri and this should have
been a clue for everyone
that he does not and it wasn't like he
just had a boneheaded moment where oh
they're called the kansas city chiefs
so that must be from kansas and he
flubbed and you know missed a couple
keys on the keyboard when he was
tweeting
no that is not what happened what
happened is
donald trump would never ever ever ever
buy or build a hotel anywhere near
kansas or missouri
would not [ __ ] do it especially
kansas city
he sees this place missouri kansas the
midwest
as gross it's gross and it's not it's
not good enough
he wouldn't [ __ ] even hardly fly to
kansas city
let alone build a hotel there are no
private jet
she she figures out that this was not
probably a good thing that she did this
was
probably not a this was probably not a
good thing that she did was
was was live stream her felonies so
she she puts on facebook how i don't
condone violence and i don't condone
vanillism and you know she tries to
really make up for what she just did
because she thinks oh it's a pr problem
this is just a pr
problem no biggie no biggie it's a pr
problem the president told us to do it
that's how these people viewed it [ __ ]
you seen the video on
cnn these guys were rummaging through
senator's desk
that possibly could have classified
information in it
and they're going oh yeah ted cruz well
he won't care he's on our side
ted cruz wants us to do this so no big
deal we won't be in [ __ ] trouble
the president told us to do it